ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show and thank you for joining us
here on the broadcast
first things first we have a little
housekeeping a matter of great import
earlier today i was contacted by members
of dan soder super pac
um where they wanted to purchase an ad
on this program
to basically uh
get my fans and the fans of this program
to vote for ari shafir
as the president of legion of skanks
and um i thought about it and
i was considering doing it
but after some real soul searching
about what is best not only for legion
of skanks but what is best for the
country
um i have decided along with the bryant
family to endorse louis j
gomez for president of legion of skanks
go to skankthevote.com at gmail and
register before
august 7th to cast a vote for
louis gomez again this is from tim
dillon and the bryant
family that is their super pac who paid
for this ad so
thank you so much now we will start the
program also we will have a
uh a hotline number later for you if you
have been sexually assaulted at the
ellen degeneres program
which uh everyone that has ever worked
there has apparently been
goosed in the dressing room at the lng
what is going on at ellen
she's out there dancing and in the back
it's a free-for-all apparently
it's the marquis de sade is running
around the dressing room and ellen
terrifying
the employees i thought she was just a
[ __ ]
that's what i thought i know people that
know her but apparently it's not that
there's sexual deviants running around
and they're making people feel
uncomfortable they're sick get up how
many people
have been sexually assaulted ellen i
won't stand for it
i won't stand for this anymore
do i like the show more now that's the
question
do i like it more now that i know that
ellen degeneres has been running a rape
room
in the back of her fun
positive show
i mean more trouble at the ellen
degeneres show former employees make
sexual misconduct
allegation dozens does is a former ellen
degeneres show employees
accuse multiple executive producers of
sexual misconduct
harassment and assault
wow degeneres apologized as an ongoing
internal investigation
into toxic worse workplace allegations
revealed
deficiencies related to the show's
day-to-day management
nearly a dozen former employees accused
head writer and executive producer
kevin lehmann of sexual misconduct
including
groping making sexually explicit
comments
and behaving inappropriately at a
company party well
it's a party while layman said he denied
any kind
of sexual impropriety multiple former
employees
accused executive producer ed glavin of
being handsy with women
and leading the team by creating a
culture of fear
and intimidation though glavin did not
comment
36 former employees
independently corroborated incidents of
sexual misconduct
36 employees at ellen
the friendly show where the woman dances
in china they don't even call it they
call it dancing lady in china
so 36 former employees that dancing lady
have been sexually assaulted and i'm not
trying to make light of that
although it is my job to and also i am
but the point is
i'm not making light of the sexual
assault i'm making light of the fact
that while it's going on
ellen is bringing out sloths to make
kristin bell
giggle
you expect that type of stuff in certain
environments fox news i don't even think
there were 36 people at fox news
and roger ailes was just running around
grabbing blondes and
throwing them out of windows for months
that guy ran that place with an iron
fist
i mean bill o'reilly was just taking
women's head and holding them in fish
tanks
and you still didn't get to 36 women
bill o'reilly paid like 38 million
dollars
to somebody god only knows what that guy
did what did you do to someone to pay
him 38 million
kill them i mean that's the type of
settlement you get when you murder
somebody
and still i don't believe and i could be
wrong but i don't believe they had
i mean it's wild and you know they
complained
ellen about it they were like you know
kevin got a little handsy or ed
got a little handsy with me and you know
she just looked at them with that stone
face because she's in the cia and she's
an asset uh
uh who is the the uh jorge campos jorge
raymond
yeah jorge campos i do this all the time
jorge ramos a guy at univision
compost the only guy to meet
stephen paddock goes in his interviewed
on
ellen it's a little weird
couple that which she's sitting next to
george w bush and they yuck it up
yucking it up about all their fun days
at abu ghraib
and she's you know there's all kinds of
emails that came out where you know
hillary clinton's on the show promoting
uh you know whatever war
that she wants to have on a wednesday
afternoon and ellen goes come on in
i'll work in between the dance and the
kristen bell sloth and you could tell us
why we gotta bomb syria hill come on
in come on down and in the back we're
gonna have women running for their lives
that's why hillary looks so comfortable
on the show because behind the scenes
you could hear the screams of women
being muffled
huh that's why you gotta dance and they
turn the music up
so you don't hear help
that's the official shot sign of the
ellen degeneres show
huh you know ellen looked at them with
that stone cold
wolf-like face she has and she was like
[ __ ] dance and the girl's like what
and ellen goes dance and they had to go
it was ellen was a trailblazer she came
out
on her abc sitcom which also sucked but
she came out and that was good
i applaud that and then she joined the
cia
that i don't live and then she
uh did a show where she danced engaged
in inane
meaningless horseshit conversation and
uh behind the scenes uh people were
being chased around with hammers
so it's been she's gone quite full
circle
uh she did suffer a lot of
discrimination when she came out of the
closet
and apparently that sat with her and she
said what if we just
you know we just set up a daytime talk
show and uh in uh
in the background we'll have uh abu
ghraib
it's a regular abu ghraib in the ellen
degeneres dressing room
you got dogs people naked stacked
together
get up abu grave photos right now this
is what's going on in ellen
this is what's going on in the back of
ellen
abu grave torture hit image
bring bring that up this is
these are the segment producers at ellen
if you're a segment producer at ellen
this is how it works out for you
and then your parents call you and
they're real proud of your big la job
and you go yeah mom
there they are go back go get the guy
with the that they're electrocuting the
guy
look at this yeah this by the way
yeah that's the an intern in ellen it
came in late
that's an intern at ellen that was got
stuck in traffic on a 405.
and you know ellen walks by that and
says nothing
she walks by and says nothing because
she's got to go sit in a chair
and do a jig with dick cheney
henry kissinger is coming on they're
going to do the charleston
what's going on over there i want
answers god darn
it
she's never had me on
what a fun interview let's practice
uh the interview you be ellen we come
out we dance we sit right down
okay hey thanks for doing the show hey
how are you there's like three people
being raped in the back you know about
that
no i have no idea hoof all right anyway
so i have a podcast called the tim
dillon show
so i want to get into this too i want to
get into this because this is a show
with a lot of serious matters and i
don't want to kid around anymore
um you can get this off by the way can
you imagine
by the way hey q anon where were you did
you care
did anyone care about this did anyone
care about this when we brutally
tortured people many of them were
innocent
did that bother anyone by the way that's
not a conspiracy theory that's the
united states government
by the way that's the united states
government designed by
uh top down by cheney rumsfeld the whole
crew
in league with psychologist mitchell and
jessen we we
took people many of them off off uh we
grabbed them off a battlefield maybe
they were terrorists maybe they weren't
maybe they were confused kids
and then we sent them the black side
shipped them all over the world and
tortured them
so again that's not chrissy teigen doing
that
that's your government
okay i want to talk about the tbs
tournament of laughs because we are no
longer on the show
and we were robbed and i love jim norton
and i
i respect him and i hope he wins he's
going up against piff the magic dragon
what an honor and
here's a reality we got to the final
four and we were let go
it's it hurts me what's your dream out
there do you have one
because my dream was to win the
tournament of laughs
on tbs when i got into comedy when i
first started doing it in a coffee house
there was also a tattoo parlor in long
island new york
okay where people would go in with like
tattoos of [ __ ]
some ex-girlfriend and they had to get
them made into something patriotic
you know can you yeah her name's carrie
can you cover that up and put blue lives
matter
please and i started there and when i
started there i dreamed that one day
there'd be a pandemic i prayed i said
hopefully
a decade in a comedy right as i'm
starting to sell tickets
there'll be a pandemic it'll shut down
the whole operation
none of us will be able to leave our
homes we'll only be able to upgrade
lo-fi sketches and we'll have to come
and not just to enjoy them to compete
with each other
that's what matters comics competing
during a pandemic not to raise money for
anything
just to do it so i dreamed of this and
it was my life's
work i fought and i worked and i and i
said to myself
if we do the right things and if china
leaks a bio weapon that the us and china
probably invented together
the only time they're gonna how great is
it gonna be when we find out the only
time
that we ever got along with china is
when we created coronavirus
because that book's coming out in five
years coronavirus has created it like
some like
u.s joint china thing i guarantee you
we're involved with china and we all
there's there's
definitely a photo of [ __ ]
us and china eating ramen and with a bat
and we said look at this [ __ ]
we're just having fun
it was some like weird convention for
[ __ ]
you know bio research darpa [ __ ] and
they created and cooked up this thing i
guarantee it it's coming out in a few
years that book by the way
and i said i said hopefully that happens
because i want to be in a position where
i can compete
tournament laughs so we made it to the
finals
we didn't think we were going to make it
there the competition was fierce
i mean fierce these other comics were
you know on drugs in homeless shelters
uploading
videos on their iphones we didn't think
we could
beat them how could we know that we were
going to
to be able to beat them you know i i
don't know what did
we went up again fortune themes to one i
don't know what happened
i don't know what her video was she was
stuck in a revolving door i don't know
it's not my
fault it's not my problem i respect her
the point is this
we won we persevered okay
and then we got to the finals to do
battle with norton
and whatever the magic dragon is and
he's one america's got talent or
something i don't know
good for him i should dress up like a
magic dragon
now you know what i was thinking by the
way the other you know david dobrik
goes around and gives people and the
face uh clan and face rug whoever these
people are
uh face covet whoever they are they give
people the lamborghinis
i said to myself what if i went around
and instead of give it giving
people a lamborghini i'd give them like
a a a stern talking to
like instead of when somebody's working
at starbucks instead of showing up with
a lamborghini
i show up i drag them outside and they
they're getting really excited like what
am i going to get and i go what are you
doing
what are you doing with your life let's
talk
why do they cry when they get the car by
the way i know i've brought this up why
do you cry
now you got to go to lamp you got a
starbucks with a lamborghini now
everybody hates you
your life is still shitty you can just
get to the horrible job
faster thank you for getting me this car
that's going to get
stolen and smashed and so i can
race to my job that i hate faster
thank you so much i'm crying thank you
for this lamborghini
that a company gave you to give me thank
you
tim dillon doesn't do that i show up
with a chris hedges book
america the farewell tour and i say
there you go
no price on knowledge how about that
i think that's a good show what if i
follow david dobrik around and i give
him beaters
like old cars that people have died in
with his like blood and
guts what if i give david dobrik cars
police cars that were burned in the
riots
just to
he looks like a chipmunk you want to eat
his face
that's why so goddamn successful
everyone i insult on the show i want to
be by the way ellen david dobrik the
mossad
so we get
[Laughter]
so we get to the finals of tournament
laughs which is literally the only thing
we've we've ever
really tried for i mean hard
hard we tried yeah we made it past
levels and
layers and yes you're telling me tim you
never told anyone to vote you barely
posted a link
you didn't know when the show was on the
website kept crashing
uh you know your aunt who supports
everything you do referred to the show
as a total embarrassment
um it was my aunt said it was so bad it
was literally confusing
um she didn't know it was a show you
know
that's good but i i
loved it i love being a part of it i
love having the honor
of being because i've loved tbs get up
the shows tbs is done
get get up what tbs has done now
you're lucky your ass got edited on that
channel
get up with tbs dot the samantha b show
thank you very much the best political
satire that's ever been made
why cause she's yelling and it's about
trump
that's what she does it's trump
uh yeah yes i was happy
to be on a network that had angie
tribeca
yes pull up angie tribeca please
it's an american comedy television
series
tribeca is a squad of lapd detectives
who investigate
the most serious cases from the murder
of a ventriloquist
to the rash of baker suicides angie
works best alone
the only problem she has a new partner
jay the squad also includes
a pop apoplectic captain chet
atkins quirky bespeckled medical
examiner dr monica scholes
and detective dj tanner this was my
favorite show
okay what else have they done up there
they just buy shows from other places
what about miracle workers
[ __ ] yeah bring up miracle workers on
tbs
this is what daniel radcliffe was in
miracle workers on tbs
man frustrated with the current state of
earth
god has pretty much given up to focus on
petty hobbies
thinking the end might be near two
determined angels trying to change his
mind
craig and eliza low-level angels
responsible for handing
handling all of humanity's prayers must
convince their boss
to save humanity and answer their most
impossible prayer yet
help two humans laura and sam fall in
love
the seven episode limited series based
on simon rich's book
turns the perception of heaven upside
down
do you people understand what an honor
it was
to be on this network that had shows
like
samantha b yells about trump angie
tribeca and whatever the hell this was
with daniel radcliffe and steve buscemi
we're on it
and lauren michael's produced it well
boohoo good
it's great anyway
i have no beef with laura michaels by
the way i'm available email me
i'll delete this whole show i'll delete
i will delete this whole show sir if you
get behind my career i'll act like it
never happened
i'll act like it never happened i'll
walk into the green room of ellen and
just throw hot acid and those [ __ ]
[ __ ] faces
i will if ellen comes back i will be the
person who sprays mace
at the uh segment producers if they get
mouthy
so we've already established tbs as a
phenomenal channel
we were lucky to be on it okay
lucky and we got to the finals and then
we said let's
let's kick it up let's kick it up a
little bit
let's not do the normal what we're doing
you know how we usually work together
and just it's me and him
we hired a crew we hired lights we had
producers we had we had about a crew of
eight people
to do these sketches literally that i
spent i spent thirty
thousand dollars producing each one of
these sketches which i will show for you
right now
they're they're good not yet not yet i
don't mean right now i mean broadcast
right now
in 38 minutes i'm kidding it's coming
soon
but i want to set the stage i spent 30
of whitney cummings money
buying producers editors writers
we had the best team i mean these people
they had been behind the best shows
angie tribeca
the the big guys samantha bee yells
about trump
all the good shows we hired the best
people
okay eps and line producers you people
don't know you're not in a biz
but we got everybody we got everybody we
got the guys who made the videos of abu
ghraib
of them raping people which seymour
hirsch said they have
and then the cia destroyed we got those
guys to do the videography
they were the same people on epstein's
island we got those people the people
that installed the blackmail equipment
in little st james came and they helped
us make these videos because they
understand how to when something is high
stakes
they get it they get it so that's what
we got
we spent a lot of money yes was it
morally questionable sure
but we wanted to win because this was my
dream
we poured our heart and soul into it we
took a week to write
a week ben came over we stayed
one week we didn't sleep we used drugs
adderall cocaine whatever
were huffing household cleaner
anything to write these sketches we were
tripping mushrooms lsd
ayahuasca we were wandering around the
desert our third eye was
open we were talking to god and the
aliens
everything that we could do to enrich
ourselves so that the
that our bodies and minds would be used
as vessels
and that those vessels would be able to
deliver a message from another world
maybe
to the people of earth that the highest
level of art
art in the sense of the priest and the
shaman
that's what we were doing we wanted to
have a religious
experience these sketches we put more
work into these sketches
than anything and they refused to
air them on television
they refused to air them on
television and i literally do not
understand why these are the most
intelligent sketches they are
smart they are sharp and they show that
we not only took this show
seriously but we have respect for the
craft of comedy
and for the great network of tbs who
brought you
great shows like samantha bee yells
about the president of the united states
for 28 minutes
and then angie tribeca
which i've never seen don't don't start
messaging me audrey hey just rebecca's
not even that bad
if somebody out there right now is like
oh you're sitting on hand she's right
back
you better understand andrew i becca was
kind of i've never
watched it we're gonna play the first
sketch now
this sketch um
took four days to shoot
how many to edit three three or four
yeah
in an editing room you had three editors
working with you mm-hmm day and night
day and night and they refused
to put this on television on the tbs
network
so now we're going to show you this
sketch which literally i've never worked
harder at anything
than i have doing this and i submitted
it to the tbs network
and they did not air it on television
and i want to know why
and i i and and maybe some of you could
let me know because when you see this
you're going to see how hard we [ __ ]
worked
hey look at this guy over here yeah
my name is frank fauci i'm tony pouchy's
son
in italy what we do is we go right in
the bath like this
we're going to bath in italy everyone
italy
you got to go to emily
it'll even go right to the map forget
about it don't be stupid
forget about it oh yeah
forget about it hey my father gonna
figure it out
my name is frank fauci the fouchy
family name i have a lot of pride in
that
don't be stupid forget about it this
coronavirus
hey look at this guy over here yeah
my name is frank fauci i'm tony fouchy's
son
he's the [ __ ] doctor tony thought
she's the doctor forget about
it hey
virus say forget about it right what are
you doing
what are you gonna do my father tony
thought she the country's in good hands
daddy gonna handle it come on down daddy
gonna handle it
he gonna get everybody vaccinated come
on don't worry about nothing forget
about it hey
hey come on donny fauci
when i was growing up my father used to
say to me used to say hey little frankie
you better be uh you better get your
vaccine
i'm making my favorite drink like this
i can put the water from the sinker like
that
look at that okay and then i put it in
here like this
forget about it i take it through the
brush i
stir it like that forgot about it
cauliflower
son frank fashion
yeah look at this guy here no coveriana
look at this guy yeah he likes it oh
it is an insult to me and to you and to
the time we spent on that that that was
not aired on television
truly and if the the ceo of that company
uh and the producers of that show do not
recognize that
for what it is and i don't wanna i don't
wanna be a part of it if you do not
recognize that sketch
and if you don't see the hours that we
put into that if you can't tell the
manpower
if you don't understand the team of
people that we assembled
to put something like that together
because we respect this show
and the network if you don't get it
i i am i wrong here
when i say that when you watch that
sketch
you think to yourself how in god's name
did they do it with only 30 grand
how did they come up with this we're
doing game of thrones level
[ __ ] here on on you know champagne
taste on a beer budget i mean
now that sketch i was frank uh dr
fauci's son frank fauci
and that was written and rewritten and
we had a team of writers kind of coming
up with those
lines and yes there was a lot of
repetition of
the forget about yes yes there was but
it was driving a point home
okay about the natural state of chaos it
is the world
and that you have to quite literally
forget about it
which i thought was a pretty good
message to deliver to tbs
the cowards the cowards at tbs
did not want to put that on the air and
to me
a little upset a little upset at the
producer that we worked with who lived
uh in a small shanty by the 405 who we
used to facetime with
uh she lived literally her her balcony
was in lane
two of the 405 and i every time i had to
face them with her i'd go are you okay
um i'm a little upset that she didn't
fight harder to get that on the air
i'm a little upset at my friend maureen
who decided to uh
to greenlight the show and then move to
canada go move to an igloo for seven
months
and uh abandon us all abandon the
artists
what about the artists
okay we don't deserve this the people
working on ellen
yes they deserve what they got that's
different
we're gonna show the second sketch now
the second sketch was even
harder the degree of difficulty have you
ever watched the olympics
you ever watched the summer olympics me
and my father used to like the winter
olympics because the speed skaters had
fun names like hey chavo
now and it wasn't racist we like to say
them hey chavo and we'd eat
ice cream pints of haagen-dazs and watch
the winter olympics and then was here
people would fall and whatever and
you know then the skier had a fun name
peekaboo street she was a white chick
um and then there were other good names
too i forget
um we always liked watching the russian
gymnasts because you know we knew
that there were stakes and when they you
know when they when they didn't
stick that landing in gymnastics they
went back to russia and they were
literally the shame of a nation you know
and then their their families would be
assassinated
and we felt like that we liked that
you know and when i would watch
the olympics you would you would you you
would see those gymnasts and they'd have
to stick the landing you'd have to stick
it you couldn't step back you could
have to stick that land and you couldn't
stumble and fall and i feel like with
this next sketch
we stuck the [ __ ] landing
we did a brilliant sketch that was
complex that was layered
had multiple meanings we had a lot going
on in the sketch
and if you know us that's not what we
usually do we usually do like a minute
or two fun topical thing
this was a real narrative
piece that we put together that the
cowards
at tbs refused to air thereby robbing us
of our
rightful victory and our place in the uh
i imagine the television hall of fame
i don't know but i'm just guessing that
that's where we would have ended up
so without further ado i'm going to play
you maybe the greatest piece of art that
me or benjamin will ever produce in our
lives
and again the cowards at tbs would not
let you see this but we will
right here on the tim dillon show
i just came home right and look here
this lady's going through my mail who
are you
how are you i'm the owner of this house
so what
i'm a neighbor in the community and i go
around and i read people's mail
to help them who do you think you are
what are you crazy you go back to your
own country you british bastard
you goddamn limey brit you go back to
your own country
you've gone full mental i'm not mental
you're mitchell
we beat you in the civil war we've been
britain in the civil war
is that your dog yeah i'm gonna kill
your
dog oh my god i'm gonna kill your dog
your stupid [ __ ]
oh christ oh now you sound australian
are you stupid what's going on
i'm i'm a white woman
i'm a white woman and i'm
the i'm in charge of the country i'm
president of my own [ __ ]
i'm president of my own [ __ ]
i'm gonna party in your house i'm happy
i'm having a party i'll kill you
get out of here you want to have sex
with me no i'll have sex with you
i'm having a party
[Music]
all right get out of here no you're not
you want my tip
kiss my ass get it
attack
yeah sickle
oh now you get out of here
i mean the proof is in the pudding the
proof is in the pudding to not put that
on
on the air to deny the effort
that went into that to me is criminal
completely criminal and i am
a little disappointed
little disappointed how many times have
i said on this program to buy gold
countless i've never said that
but it's only because i don't always
want to give away the secrets
the tricks of the trade
something about owning gold bullion you
know
it's not like this fake paper currency
something real you could hold on to it
i would i would if you have a retirement
encounter roth ira or something like
that it's very
important to convert a certain
percentage of that i think to gold to a
precious metal
and that's why today i want to tell you
about the birch gold group
as one of the top dealers of physical
precious metals in the united states
birch gold group helps americans
diversify their savings with gold and
silver
customers can purchase for physical
possessions or convert a portion of
their ira
or 401k into an ira backed by physical
precious metals
burj gold group specializes in gold iras
so this should be the primary focus of
what you do
okay six trillion already spent on covid
the national debt is soared past 26
trillion
what impact do you think that's going to
have on the value of the dollar who's
paying for it all
soon it's not going to be the world's
currency everything's going to collapse
do not wait for the bottom to fall out
now is the time to protect your savings
including your ira or your 401
gold thrives in uncertain times like
this in fact
amidst the turmoil of the past few
months gold has soared to
all-time highs it's very true
you know there's a there's a certain
amount of people out there that are
preppers
listening to the show preppers got to
canned food
maybe got a little bit of uh you know
maybe
maybe maybe have a little underground
condo for one at all
you need to get the gold they will they
will ship you physical gold that's the
coolest thing about
the birch gold group is you can you can
have it sent somewhere or they'll send
it directly to you
and you could put it in your home and
you could sit there with a gun
which is what i would do that's the only
way
to get through this time sit
on gold bars with a gun
and let it all happen
the company that i trust with precious
metal purchases is birch gold
right now thanks to a little known irs
tax law you can even move your ira
or eligible 401k into an ira
physical gold and silver account it's
perfect for those who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings
from any more uncertainty or downturns
and stocks the market's going to bleed
the only reason the market's done
somewhat okay is because they've priced
out all of the horrors that are
happening in the world
the market's not a reflection of reality
it's completely fake it's propped up
it's gonna come tumbling down be smart
convert your 401k or your roth ira into
gold
get the gold shipped to your house show
it to your children
tell them it can one day be theirs make
them
fight over it make them fight to first
blood over the gold
toughen them up people
kids love gold
contact brooch gold group to request a
free info kit on physical precious
metals
see if diversifying into gold makes
sense for you
it's a comprehensive 20-page kit and
this is all fun and games we can have a
lot of fun with this but we all know
what's coming here
and having a percentage of your
retirement account in gold is actually
very smart
stock market's gonna get is gonna be
shellacked
you might as well get that gold
you could get a 20-page kit that reveals
how gold and silver can protect your
savings
and how you can legally move your ira or
401 out of risky stocks and bonds
and into precious metals a lot of people
are doing it a lot of wealthy people are
doing it
a lot of smart people are doing it i bet
you slade maxwell did it
and don't you don't you say
wwgd what would just lane do
to get you no cost no obligation kit
text tim
to four seven what is that ben
four seven four seven four seven yeah
text
tim to 474747 for limited time
see how you could qualify for up to 10
000 in free
precious metals on your purchase wow
what so if you qualify you might get ten
thousand dollars in free precious metals
on your purchase
text tim the four seven four seven four
seven do it
why not learn even if you're not gonna
do it learn
what it's like to have actual gold
remember ducktales yeah
what did they swim around in a pit of
cash remind me
banker's notes bonds
stock certificates what did the
ducktales
ducks swim around in gold
correct
and who was the rich duck scrooge mcduck
scrooge he did what he needed to do
who was launch pad mcquack
wasn't he like the villain no i don't
think he was
launch pad mcquack
he was a pilot
he works for scrooge mcduck as his pilot
and he flies cocaine for scrooge mcduck
he later became darkwing duck sidekick
so he became who's the villain in
ducktales
darkwing duck right
so he turned i want kentucky fried
chicken now
the point is this i'm on slim fast i
won't because i'm doing a
thing with big j and soda and ari and
volcano
birch gold group that's what we're
talking about right now
and we're saying if it's good enough for
the ducks
who was it huey louie and dewey if it's
good enough for those lovable ducks
and screw and that smart businessman
launch bed seemed like he lost oxygen at
birth or something wrong but he made
he did the right thing but they swam in
gold they were comforted by the feeling
of gold against their skin
let that be you text him
to four seven four seven seven
get involved in gold
it's not enough to just be
aware that the world is ending you must
take
steps to protect yourself
in these uncertain times
even if you don't have a retirement
account you can convert cash
to gold
do it thank you
ridge wallet yum bridge wallet buy the
wallet it's a minimal front pocket
wallet that's designed to streamline
what you carry
every day it has thirty thousand five
star reviews and it's a better way to
carry your cash and cards i use it ben
uses it everyone on the show uses it
go and buy this wallet okay go to
ridge.com tim
and use the code tim the link is in the
description
ridge is great they're metal wallets
they're sleek they're small you can
easily sanitize them
with a sanitizer there you put them in
the front pocket it's
like you don't even have it it's easy if
you get mugged people won't
find it you know you could get brutally
beaten on the street and they won't get
your ridge
it's very important so do that okay
it's sleek it's got two metal plates
bound together by a durable elastic band
the ridge looks nothing like a
traditional wallet
titanium carbon fire and aluminum
options ensures there's an option for
everybody
okay i love ridge
do you love ridge yes
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
tim do you like the show do you enjoy
the show do you value what we do do you
you want to try a wallet a get a nice
little wallet
it's ridge.com tim and use the code tim
we've talked about this at nauseum i've
done lots of ads for ridge
i mean we've we i i've spent hours on
the ridge wallet truly
it's now time for you to do something
for me why don't you
do something for me and go to ridge.com
and use the promo code tim and if you
don't use the promo code tim
don't even do it use a promo code tim
why you get free worldwide shipping and
returns if you don't like it and you'll
love it
dummy you're gonna love it
you're gonna love it remember the guy
that didn't get the ridge wallet that
was gonna
and he decided not to remember what
happened to him
go to ridge.com tim and use the code tim
i'm telling you you're not gonna regret
this i love it
i use it ben uses it
ridge wallet is the official wallet
of little saint james in the virgin
islands
it is used by jeffrey epstein gislane
maxwell alan dershowitz new mexico
governor bill richardson
bill clinton amongst others it is the
elite wallet
it is the wallet that everybody uses
at littlefin champs
so if you wanna
be cool
get the ridge wallet the official
every product on this show is official
magic spoon cereal
bridge wallet so go to ridge wallets a
lifetime warranty if you love it and
free returns if you don't
can you move it so i can say something
else please well this is that's all it
is right there well that's all they're
getting then
buy the wallet before i kill myself on
air
thank you so the epstein docks just
dropped by the way uh they've
declassified some documents
i mean alan dershowitz is such a [ __ ]
pedophile
you kind of have to respect how hard in
the paint he's going
he's literally trolling at this point
like he's clearly guilty of like
everything i think he was running the
ring by the way
i don't i think jeff finches lane were
like ins you know instrumental but it
seems like alan dershowitz was like
literally doing everything he's like
written articles where he's like let's
lower the age of consent
it's like that's not a great article to
surface if you're
literally being accused credibly accused
of like raping children on an island
um i love this alan dershowitz defends
op a
op-ed suggesting that age of consent for
sex should be lowered
it's great alan dershowitz the outspoken
controversial harvard law
emeritus professor is defending himself
on twitter after an op-ed resurfaced in
which he suggested
the age of consent for statutory rape
cases should be lowered
in a 97 op-ed in the la times suggesting
that 15 was a reasonable age of consent
oh boy no matter how old the partner was
whoa
wow keep it in your pants
dersh what a sick [ __ ]
i mean god statutory rape is an outdated
concept alan dershowitz now go to the uh
the documents that just came out
um which people's name you know bill
clinton is named in them
i had a little fun joke on twitter i
said uh you know trump is about to ban
tick tock
um so if you want to see 16 year old
girls dancing you got to take a plane
with bill clinton which
is probably true i love bill clinton was
like speaking at john lewis's memorial
and he's like talking about the civil
rights movement and he's like literally
i mean
go hide doesn't anyone hide
i mean so clinton is now named in these
documents
by a witness who says he was at the
island he was at little st james
with two young women from new york that
is what
um people are saying about bill clinton
other people named of course are alan
dershowitz new mexico governor bill
richardson
there's other people named ron berkel
supermarket billionaire
friends with clinton um there's other
people as well
you know their names are kind of
escaping me i think matt lauer maybe
oh really i think matt lee said
something about matt lauer
uh being named uh as well there's just
some
odd stuff floating around
uh with that and um
these are the first set of documents
that are going to be released
there are more documents that are coming
out
uh about this case
and um
yeah i mean everybody was really
just lane maxwell obviously
was not only um recruiting these women
she was abusing them as well
and and that is why you know when we had
whitney webb on the program whitney was
like
why is she not being charged with that
much more serious offense
um so governor bill richardson denies
involvement in epstein's sex driving
imagine all of these people like they
thought they were kind of going to get
away with it and they almost did like
they're almost all dead
that's the other thing like you're gonna
see the line of demons that get trotted
out for this
they're almost dead they're literally
octogenarians they're 80 years old
they're almost dead
they they would they were almost i mean
they should
want to get covet these people now they
should want to get covert r.i.p herman
cain
godfather's pizza you know raycomb
showed me a fun thing um herman cain of
course died if coronavirus
you know didn't wear a mask whatever you
also had stage four cancer who's 74 we
get it right
but you know coronavirus probably
speeded it up um
but uh herman cain godfather's pizza
which is like just the most
i mean it is i'm racist against italians
all the time because it's fun
but like godfather's pieces like we'll
make your pizza you can't refuse
you know because you're all criminals um
and then they have they had some guy
tweeted the godfather's pizza
mafia name generator get this up
godfather's pizza your mob name
by the way if you're ordering
godfather's pizza i mean
covet is the best thing to happen to you
so create your godfather's pizza mob
name so ben
yours is blue eyes the ant
using your first and last international
initials create your godfather's pizza
mobster name
mine is teflon tony the iceman
what are you supposed to do with these
names do they call you that name when
they open the door to your trailer to
give you godfather's pizza
hey are you richie the clown
just open the door to your trailer hey
we got to meet lovers for richie the
clown
his muscles the grosser there
we got a supreme pizza for mussels the
grocer
how about whitie the wise guy
how about fast frankie the animal
his hot stuff to snake there
we have some wings made
at godfather's pizza
um but these people almost got away with
it and they're all
yeah the bill clinton looks pretty dead
you know when you see him at the john
lewis
memorial he's he's gone vegan he can't
[ __ ] anymore
he has a heart problem i mean that guy
it's all coming apart
imagine living long enough to see
yourself become the hero in the 90s
the progressive hero like bill clinton
when i was growing up him and hillary
were like
progressive heroes and that you know
james carville you know the raging cajun
would be like
he'd be like you know revving up the
[ __ ] war room
and everybody that you know like we got
the real candidate we got
bill and hillary we're going all the way
and like you'd see them he'd
be giving stump speeches and he was
amazing at this you know he was amazing
at this he'd be in [ __ ] wherever that
he'd [ __ ] be
you know in oklahoma or iowa
pennsylvania arkansas colorado wherever
he was
you know he'd be at a diner shaking
somebody's hand or
kissing a baby eating a piece of pie and
he'd get up he'd be like i love you and
i love you and
you know this country and everybody
would be so into it
so imagine living through that like
being
at the height of power you're being
worshipped
and then you live long enough to see
yourself
become i mean it's the old quote right
you know you die a president or you live
long enough to see yourself become a
pedophile
it's the old famous quote but think
about the journey that that guys had
everybody loved them and everybody got
mad he got his dick sucked
and now he thought that was bad
now 30 years later he's opening the
newspaper and they're like we know
you're [ __ ] kids on the island he's
like oh
god
he's like disgraced beyond disgrace
and him and hillary won't go away like
they won't go away they're still there
after herman cain's death you know
republicans uh all went on facebook to
make uh
you know not this is my favorite thing
that people do on facebook now they go
this is not a political post
i don't want anybody to fight me on this
it's not a political post
but isn't it fair to say that dr fauci
created aids
that's my favorite thing people do on
facebook they go this is not a political
i don't want to fight you know i don't
want to fight
this is not a political post i'm asking
questions
can i ask a question the question is and
again it's not political
it's not political
are the people who died from covert
pedophiles
not political i'm just asking
are we using covert to get rid of
pedophiles just a question
throwing it out there please don't
attack me this is facebook
it's a reasonable question to ask
and now i can tell that the republicans
are
they're acting like they're going to
lose they're going to lose and they
should lose i mean trump should lose
this election forget politics i mean
this is not
the left is so [ __ ] crazy that he may
not they're running a corpse
i mean they're mentally ill you know
they're talking about like the gender
identity of the covent bats
you know i mean it's it's a it's a real
it's a circus over there and you know
how i feel about it all
but trump's really not running on a
great record here i mean he's not
running on a great
you know my friends like he's kept us
out of a lot of wars and it's like
yeah but also uh not the civil war
that's coming it's like he's kept us out
of a lot of wars and you just go to like
oh you you know you should go to youtube
and you just hear
these major american cities are on fire
not exactly
it's not exactly the most this isn't the
most peaceful time
um here's why no republic because
they're getting sensitive
they always lose when they become
[ __ ] and if you're a conservative out
there
and you're in any position of power and
i know some of you listen to this
program
um uh listen to me now
you're you're acting when herman cain
died and a lot of people on the left
were like listen
he didn't wear a mask and now he's dead
and and they were you know whatever
dancing on the guy's grave and you guys
were like you guys were like i can't
believe
that people would speak of the dead in
the way that they are
i am whenever you become like righteous
indignation
and for let people dance on the graves
of their political opponents
it is all that you've given them they
have nothing left
you've refused to give them health
insurance the serfs should be allowed to
mock the lord who died
can you imagine you pull the turnips out
all day and then you go back to your
hovel
with your family and then they go you
know lord
the lord was stricken they found him in
a bed with a [ __ ]
what are you supposed to say like don't
speak of the lord that way
eat your rabbit cruel and be grateful no
let them you don't give them retirement
health care
everybody is going to dance with the
graves of their political enemies it's
it's kind of nice it's kind of nice that
this country allows people
it's kind of nice if ruth bader ginsburg
dies
republicans would be like she was a
witch jesus christ killed her
and jesus christ wants her to be dead so
that we can have a conservative on the
court
who funds ice because christ loves ice
christ fries christ likes
those immigrants getting ripped out of
there that's what jesus if jesus was
alive today he'd be in ice
you'll all dance under grave so stop the
preeming
moralism that's when you're coming from
the posture of
losing righteous indignation
is what losers do when they're about to
lose
i cannot believe it i don't understand
what kind of gentleman would speak of
the dead in the
you're going to lose now
here's how you beat them when they
say herman cain is dead you say no he's
not and you get his corpse and you sit
him on
fox news and you [ __ ] have tucker
costs and put his hand by and you
puppet act herman get you weekend at
bernie's herman cain's corpse if you
want to win
do you want a winner yeah yes or yes yes
sir yes do you want to win
liberals say herman died because he
didn't wear a mask say
[ __ ] you herman ain't dead prop him
right
up next to sean hannity
and spray him down with formaldehyde or
hannity can handle the smell
and you sit herman cain there on fox
news and you move his mouth and he goes
i'm not
dead [ __ ] you
i'm still not worried i don't know what
i'm doing raycon's voice naturally to me
and have ray come to his voice listen to
mary
that's how you beat them you you fight
fire with fire stop the righteous
indignation
weakened at bernie's cane have trump
bring him around to stump speeches
have trump bring herman cain's corpse
around to to events
he should be the keynote speaker at the
republican national convention
the ghost of herman cain get ghoulish
get ghoulish with it you said the
liberals are ghoulish and yes they are
they get a little nuts with it
like herman cain's dead and good and i
[ __ ]
can't you know they they go nuts but you
go
more nuts and say herman's not dead the
spirit of herman cain is alive
and you bring him out at the republican
national convention to give the keynote
speech
you bring his body out and yes it'll be
uncomfortable
and yes people aren't gonna like it but
the ship's going down anyway folks
so why not [ __ ] fight fire with a
little bit of fire
it's true that's my idea
you refuse to let that man die his ideas
must live
you say herman's ideas must live i don't
know what they were he had some plan
called the
the 999 plan about taxes and was kind of
like his pizza thing everyone kind of
ridiculed
it but he's having fun god bless him
he's a black uh
guy worth worth uh 100 million dollars
he [ __ ] kicked ass in life
herman can't kick ass in life and the
people that are [ __ ] on
herman cain suck he kicked ass in life
he was a black guy that suffered all
kinds of discrimination and he made
money
the way you should in america killing
fat people with a racist italian
restaurant
i i couldn't respect herman cain more
and and me suggesting that trump trot
his body around to get votes
he seems like it is disrespectful but
it's really knocks i do like herman cain
i would say do it to anyone beta
ginsburg any of them don't let any of
them die i don't care
the 999 plan was a tax proposal that was
the centerpiece of her mccain's 2012
campaign
for the republican party's nomination
for president of the united states it
was introduced
august 2011 the plan called for
replacement of all current taxes
such as the payroll tax cap gains tax
and estate tax with a 9
personal income tax nine percent federal
sales tax and a nine percent corporate
tax by the way
sounds fine i'm for it r.i.p herman cain
ray connier buds apple socks they're
they're they're they're
they're involved with china they're
going to kill your family
ray kind of earbuds started about half
the price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market that it's the same
thing it's even better
and it's cheaper just buy them what do
you need
celebrities use them mike tyson snoop
dogg
melissa etheridge it's an interesting
coupling huh it's an interesting crew
ray j started the brandy's brother
half the price the newest model the
everyday e25 earbuds are their best ones
yet with six hours of play time
six hours seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass
and a more compact design it gives you a
nice noise isolating fit
it's a good backup pair of headphones
you're gonna lose your apple headphones
you're gonna lose them and then what
you're gonna go back to apple with your
tail between your legs and your hand on
your ass
and they're gonna tell you what an apple
stand six feet
order online pick it up later what's
your temperature
wish let me vaccinate you what are you
doing
dr fauci's gonna come out and [ __ ]
start spraying you with a water cannon i
don't know what's gonna happen but [ __ ]
that you don't need that [ __ ]
you don't need that [ __ ]
raycons are inexpensive but functional
and even better than functional they're
great
what was the what was what's your
favorite thing about the raycon
they charge quickly very good
and the airpods always hurt my ears
these don't hurt my ears at all
you know what my favorite thing about
the raycon is what
truly what okay i was being
mugged the other day i don't know why
that's funny
i was being mugged the other day
mugged
and the guy noticed the ray cons in my
ears
and he said i'm not going to mug you
and he didn't
you [ __ ] me
why because raycon is good
it's very late folks bye raycon.com
tim byraycon.com
stop going to apple they're trying to
kill your kova 19.
apple china cover 19. fouchy
magic spoon is my favorite cereal it has
zero sugar 11 grams of protein and three
net
plucked that black trunk [ __ ]
i should have had more magic spoon
cereal yeah i'm having a stroke
four flavors cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry it tastes amazing it's like
the cereals you had as a kid
everybody loves it greg gutfeld the fox
news who many of you hate and
probably maybe some of that is
justifiable i don't know he's very nice
to me retweets me but
uh you know he likes it he said
something nice about
it today don't [ __ ] use his coat if
he has one
magicspoon.com tim dillon this is a
cereal to get your kids hooked on if
they like sugary [ __ ]
get em this cereal because it's very low
in sugar very low in carbs
it is high protein okay this is a very
healthy cereal
that mimics the flavor of the sugary
cereals you had as a kid
okay if you're if you're on a keto diet
this is definitely
on there if you go to magicspoon.com tim
dillon magicspoon.com station
post a photo of you with magic spoon i
will repost it on my instagram
and then i will select one lucky winner
to see my show at madison square garden
next week
where i'm performing in madison square
garden with billy eilish
so how about that magicspool.com but i
will repost you on instagram and i'll
plug
your information i'll say follow
whatever if you do that but you got to
show me with the magic spoon that you
bought with my promo code don't lie
we're going on the honor system
magicspoon.com tim dillon use the code
tim dillon for free shipping
free shipping's big cereal is not that
pricey for what it is
how pricey is life
how expensive is death
you don't want to leave your family with
a burden live
magic spoon and i've said it before
is the official cereal
of little saint james
everybody ate magic spoon on the island
that's why they look so good
it's good trust me
i wouldn't lie to you i'm not a liar am
i a liar
i'm a pathological liar but not about
this
not about this no sir
you put the cereal in the bowl and you
eat it and you
shut your mouth
with the magic spoon in it
and what happens is you're then healthy
you're a healthy boy or girl or a
non-binary gender non-specific organism
that deserves all the respect like
anyone else
just put the cereal in your throat
put it in your throat wouldn't that be
great if like these were old-school
cereal ads like corn flakes like
that was corn flakes motto they were
like put it in your
throat cheerios
cheerios is fake oh it's a
heart healthy no it's everyone who has
cereal cheerios dies
everyone who eats plain cheerios is a
racist not honey nut
uh but plain cheerios they are racists
you like racism keep doing that uh
you're not a racist
this might not be a great pitch for this
audience but
magicspoon.com tim dillon and use the
code tim dillon
for free shipping do it
post it tag me i'll repost it
let's start a revolution a serial
revolution
but my point about these epstein fox is
they're somehow
they're so [ __ ] old they can't really
be punished anymore
for anything they've done
get bill richardson's statement out
they're going to blame it on this idiot
they're going to blame it all on bill
richardson
billy eilish's new song where she's uh
hopeful about the future i
i listen a little bit of that god love
her
i hope she comes on the program no hate
to billy eilish it's
listen hey it's not really for me
i bet i'm not for her she's doing a lot
better than i am in this business and
she always will
tina turner had real gravel in the voice
because she had blood in her throat
that's what i want the authenticity you
know
everybody under 25 has anxiety shut up
you don't
if you're if you're under if you're if
you're under 25
and you have millions of dollars you're
no longer allowed to have anxiety
you're no longer allowed call it
something else
you can't have anxiety if you're 25 and
you got millions of dollars
well tim that's not fair mental health
is complex
shut up herman cain's corpse coming
these alleys why did tbs not put those
sketches on you are they out of their
[ __ ] minds
these allegations and inferences are
completely false
governor richardson has never even been
contacted by any party regarding this
lawsuit
to be clear governor richardson gets it
in he gets his dick wet but it's always
with people
that are of age and if some of them
aren't of age he doesn't know that
everybody looks kind of the same
governor richardson has never been to mr
epstein's residence in the virgin
islands although he loves his ranch in
new mexico
where he's from governor richardson
loves that ranch and they love to eat
tamales and hunt
children kidding governor richardson has
never met mrs
goofy virginia three
um in other news and this is all i'll
kind of be saying about this
um you know when the comedy store in los
angeles opens back up
i will be doing all of the spots so from
one
when do the shows run from eight to two
a.m i will be doing
all of the spots at the comedy store in
la when they uh reopen
i'm a little i mean you know i got to
get the reps in i got to get the time
and i got to get stage time in
vote for louis gomez my good friend
louis i love
louis is one of those people who i truly
like more and more
all the time and i and i start out
liking him a lot um
because he sees the world for what it is
i i appreciate that
um follow ray kump on twitter he's got
the best twitter out there right now
it's better than mine i just have more
followers because
i like make stuff like videos and
everything but in terms of actual raw
tweets i mean redcom's twitter is
absolutely insane i mean when he hits he
hits very very hard
he's got 12.6 000 uh followers but go to
my instagram because i i have some of
his amazing tweets on my instagram
ray will of course be back on the
program soon on our patreon
um and then he'll we'll have him on the
regular episode too
my dad just blurted out in the middle of
dinner what's a gender binary so i just
grabbed him and pulled him across the
table and started hitting him on the
temple
the soul shaker screaming you entitled
white [ __ ] don't you embarrass me at
this olive garden
keep going our grandparents spent their
20s cowering in europe using world war
ii as an excuse to avoid the
responsibilities of adulthood
while our generation is left to shutter
the burden a shoulder the burden of
running countless news satire blocks
which nobody asked for nobody thinks are
funny
my roommate has been holed up in her
room all day leaving threatening
voicemails for her ex-boyfriend's
children
now she's blasting gilmore girls at max
volume and hysterically crying
i just want her to go to sleep so i can
eat her meatball sandwich
republicans people need to take personal
responsibility also republicans
buy this gun for your baby you [ __ ]
deadbeat more republicans
oh my god that baby has a gun shoot it
in the spine
democrats we're going to give poor
people a pencil
and this one this might be this is my
new favorite my mom locked herself in
the bathroom crying
because i kept showing her photoshops i
made of ep scene in the pulp
now i'm threatening to kill myself if
she doesn't come out this is what
speaking truth to power looks like
at raycombe on twitter r-a-y-k-u-m-p i
mean just tweeting from
uh i mean a hole somewhere
he's living in the hole that we found
saddam husseinis go follow my instagram
at tim j
dillon d-i-l-l-o-n go retweet the video
we did about the tick-tock kids that was
a lot of fun great we made the video one
my friend's son uh casted
all of the kids in the video because i
don't really know anybody in their teens
and all the comedians that do i don't i
can't really talk to anymore
now we're kidding this is a this is a
comedy show
and we're doing funny things about
things that aren't funny
now
now so these kids were great can we play
that on the show
let's play this this is a fun one here
here's what we're satirizing by the way
if you don't know this there's a guy
that runs around
like la's been taken over by these tick
tock kids and i live up the block from
the steakhouse called boa and
the food at boa is atrocious i'm from
new york
perhaps you've heard of it and we do
steak very well so does texas
l.a doesn't ellie doesn't do much well
except like pokeballs and sushi and
breakfast and beverly hills hotel nice
pancakes and
scrambled eggs locks whatever and
mexican food right and
and vietnamese like you know uh lada's
thai they do great thai
but they don't do greek well not
italian other than nancy silverton's
austria moza best restaurant la in my
opinion
they don't really do italian that well
greek italian
seafood steak remain east coast it's
just what it is
i don't know about indian food uh it's
not for me
i know that it's great i've had it and
i've enjoyed it a few times
but i just don't eat it regularly i
don't need a new food
to like you know there's some foods
where i'm like let me not let me not get
really into another food
um but these kids and they're tiny
they're tiny they're like children
and they run around the steakhouse with
like bedazzled jackets on and they're
dressed like hypebeasts and everything
and uh grown-ups paparazzi have to stand
outside
and ask them about their lives like hey
man
hey griffin you broke up with dixie or
whatever and
and these kids are like and you know
these kids are their kids they have no
idea what's going on
they they were going like this two years
ago
now they're millionaires they're living
in la they're being followed her and by
the way it ain't kids it ends
so get that money while you can because
it ends okay
but as of right now they're living the
dream they're they're [ __ ] each other
they're in this big house in the hills
they're being uh their parents are
probably out of work
their parents are probably shot the kids
are like supporting their families
and again just from this
and i mean you imagine when they grow up
they're like what were you doing during
the pan
grandpa what were you doing during the
pandemic
well i was dancing in the hollywood
hills for millions of dollars
an energy drink company gave me five
million dollars
but wasn't it wasn't everyone dying yes
but i was dancing i was dancing
and making money so these tick tock kids
are just
running los angeles right now and there
and there are guys you probably came to
la to be like filmmakers
you know life sahara and instead
or even be like paparazzi like sandra
bullock like
right people that have done things i let
me follow around sofia vergara
somebody who's done something
now they got to follow these like 16
year old kids in the starbucks
while these kids come out and they're
like hi and he's like hey
what's going on with you and they're
like
i'm just like i'm just like
yeah um so we made this video satirizing
this guy
and i i hope this gets to him because i
respect him i i respect anyone's hustle
and
i i i don't want anyone to get hurt but
let me just say what would be funny
i always worry when i say this i always
worry when i say things like this
would it be funny i don't want any of
the kids getting hurt
but would it be funny if this guy blew
his head off in front of all of them
like one day he just had enough and they
really didn't want to answer his
questions
and he said okay charlie demilia what do
you think about and she's like i don't
really have time and he goes you don't
look at me for the rest of your life why
do you remember this
i have a degree in film from nyu and
then just these kids wouldn't care you
know what they do they go
but it'd be funny to just his brain
matter splatters on like their high
piece
sweatshirts and by the way that's not a
that's not shade on him i
they say shade shade is a new word uh
and it's an old word shade really but i
i've just gotten into it now
trump it's not but it's really see
everyone thinks trump invitations are
that hard they're actually not that hard
like if anyone practiced they're kind of
jail jlkovan is the best trump imitation
ever it's [ __ ] hilarious
um so we made this video
you can watch it hey olivia
what's up good morning what are you guys
doing outside my house ah
come on you know we love you listen
olivia what's going on let me ask you
there's so much happening
do you think ryan should be canceled for
dressing up like a japanese person
i'm not really into cancer culture ah
all right
all right what do you got to say to the
fans what's going on what are you
working on right now
lots of stuff i can't talk about yeah of
course
yeah that's right i don't know ryan
dressed up though like a geisha in
seventh grade that was very insensitive
hey madison what's up ladies guess who
yes you're madison you're never gonna
guess what i have in my possession right
now what do you have
i have your report card from last year
you
failed chemistry that class was hard
your mother paid for a tutor
talk to me man what's going on what's up
man what are you doing man
dude what's next for you that's what
everybody wants to know it's like what's
next for you
oh i really want to become an actor an
actor yeah man so what type of acting
are you trying to do
uh like you know like actually like
where you're like talking
yeah yeah i feel that man i feel that yo
geo what's up fam what uh
what's up what's going on with you and
ashley bro i mean
you know i can't really speak on that
right now i'm just just focused on the
music
yeah what kind of music you gonna put
out uh
it's like it's that new [ __ ] yeah like
what like
little dicky meets enya [ __ ] yeah man
yeah are you okay to drive yeah i'm good
all right sam
you sure you're good bro i'm good look
at a recorder mid-tick-tock
so what's going on you think we're going
to war with china
it's not falling out me and my friends
you're literally like 50 years old
please get out
leave go about go go yeah miss you you
took a trip back home what was that like
yeah i wasn't good man my mom just
passed away uh to covet so
oh man that doesn't slap no it doesn't
no rip mom you know what i'm saying
yeah that's right r.i.p mom
yeah that kid was great that kid get in
one take
like jay-z
one take uh that was fun though we did
that
uh video about the uh tick tock i
thought some of the tic tac kids would
share it but of course
we're we're still below them that
they're they're living on a cloud they
don't
even want to know people like me exist
and by the way i don't blame them
um and it's also comedy's not for
good-looking people that where things
are going well then not my comedy you
know
not any comedy i've ever respected it's
like comedy needs to be for people who
like my comedy needs to be for people
who are like
who are like currently on fire
like that's who my comedy's for it's not
for like a kid who just got eight
eight thousand dollars to wear a
sweatshirt for a minute in a video
it's for people who are literally
their leg is being amputated as we speak
and not even in the hospital by like
another member of antifa who's like [ __ ]
the cops
got uh you know i don't know
jasmine's leg i don't know what the
antifa names are just not jasmine but
whatever
fern what if it's if
a general was named fern
antifa needs a head they're too random
we need to we nee you need someone to
negotiate you need to be
like a fat non-binary purple hair like
you need
you need like a like a uh
uh dick tracy villain to be the head of
antifa so you can negotiate with like
trump
she like threatened trump we're heading
into like a comic
graphic novel world so we need that
i'm saddened frelin i'm saddened for the
people that work at that program
i'm saddened for the decay
um i'm saddened by the cowardice of the
executives at tbs
that would not allow me what i consider
two of the greatest pieces of art ever
produced
on the air okay
because apparently they didn't make
sense
and were literally insane
and it was clear i didn't really care
and i just submitted
nonsense of me playing with the bulldog
i mean that's that was their view
can do you even see how they get that i
don't i don't
tim dilloncomedy.com no dates now or
ever
kidding hopefully we'll be out there
eventually uh tim j
dillon di lloyd on instagram go follow
me on instagram
go follow me on twitter tim j dillon go
follow raycomp
go follow ben avery what's your handle
shut up
go follow a lot of oscar go down to fila
keep scrolling down the instagram feed
let's find it old let's find a really
old instagram photo
well that was when oscar joined a
national guard there
well oscar oscar is a very i mean
he joined the national guard right as a
protest we're happening he's very
suspect
right now he's oscar is promoting that
that that jamaican doctor
who says it diseases come from [ __ ]
demons in your sleep
go old i want older go older
i want to see the old world i mean i
know that we're back into the old world
right now but i'm like
wow go up go up go up
go up go up go up
go to the left no no down down down go
to the right
bring that up
new host of fighter in the kit
good night everybody
laughs